Joe Biden has been warned a bunch of
liberal columnists are urging the
president to boot Kamala off the ticket
but the veeps insane cheerleaders in the
Press are threatening to take down his
campaign if he doesn't
I would be very careful President Biden
about getting rid of Kamala Harris
because we will not support you if Biden
gets rid of Kamala Harris and inserts
someone else he will lose the black vote
I don't want a White's plan but you
might be underestimating the black
community I think I am I think some of
the soft bigotry is showing in the
progressives women always have to work
hard in men I don't tell you two that
but women of color it with power I think
she's threatening but Joe may have no
choice because top Democrats keep
throwing her under the bus
the best running mate for this president
he thinks so and that's what matters and
by the way I think so she's very
politically astute you think she is the
best running mate though she's the vice
president of the United States so people
say to me well why isn't she doing this
or that I said because she's the vice
president that's the job of description
you don't do that much what do you make
of speaker Pelosi's answer there I mean
there didn't seem to be anything wrong
uh with that answer that's President
Biden's choice and I think she's an
excellent running mate for president
Biden
okay Shannon would you like to White
explain the issue here if if she does
not appear on the ticket will black
voters abandon the Biden campaign I
don't know but they there's polling
showing they have been in some ways
because they don't think he's delivered
on a lot of things that they were hoping
he would deliver on so that's probably
his bigger problem but when I heard
about this I thought about do you guys
remember getting this memo August of
2020 called we have her back it was
before she was named at the ticket but
her name was she's probably or possibly
going to be the VP and it was a memo
from all of these groups to the heads of
news divisions saying we're watching
everything that you do don't use
pictures of women that look angry don't
talk about them being ambitious as a
negative thing don't talk about their
appearance don't stereotype and it goes
on in here to say we know you've been
working in your newsrooms for diversity
and so we're going to hold you to
account in the way that you cover her
this new thing gives me very much shades
of we're watching you and if you get
this wrong we're going to call you out
it's like the impeachment threat that
they said to the news Chiefs Greg that
was a kiss of death by Nancy I don't
know if Kamal is going to be too happy
yeah not a ringing endorsement she's
basically saying that you know she does
a capable job because it's a really easy
job to do that's like saying I prefer a
house plant over a pet because you don't
have to feed it and it won't wet the
carpet but uh
I heard the view was going on a hunger
strike but only between commercials I
I look Democrat on Democrat action they
should create a category for that on
PornHub and it's good to see Dems
calling out everyone else races tour
also Dems who will get their taste of
that medicine because now the monster is
devouring themselves it's like they now
realize that wow they elected the oldest
widest perhaps racist president ever Joe
Biden because they'd rather win than
stick to their own principles and now
they're going to do this it's too late
you guys already threw her aside before
that's right so do you think she stays
on the ticket Pierce well if you're the
Republicans you hope she does you hope
the Biden and Kamala Harris are the duo
that go powering into the next election
uh the president who appears to have
completely lost his marbles and a vice
president who by any poll that I've seen
for people of all skin colors is deemed
to be completely useless the Democrats
have a real problem here they can bang
on about Trump all they like but Trump's
chances of being re-elected president
increase with every gaffe that Biden
makes and the knowledge that people have
that if he's not able to run which many
people think is now increasingly
unlikely then is it even remotely
feasible that Kamala Harris could beat
Donald Trump absolutely not and this
whole thing about I think one of them
described it a soft bigotry right if you
say that Kamala Harris is
underperforming you are a soft bigot
whatever that means I mean I don't know
how you can have sort of degrees of
bigotry but it reminded me a little bit
of when I left my previous job hosting a
Morning Show back in the UK you may
remember I I criticized Meghan Markle
for what I I believe let's be polite and
just say that I said I wouldn't believe
her if she read a weather report right
and this was deemed to be racist that
the only reason I said that was because
of her skin color which obviously was
complete nonsense this whole narrative
building already that if Joe Biden was
to ditch Kamala Harris
anyone that thinks of that is a good
idea is a racist it's ridiculous how
have we got to this place where
criticism immediately is racist it's the
same with the Trans debate isn't it
we've talked about this many times if
you think of six foot four inch
biological male should not be dominating
women's swimming you are a transphobe it
is ridiculous uh so look they've got big
problems I mean if I was a Democrats and
I'm not obviously but if I was a an
American Democrat right now I would be
seriously worried and I'd be thinking
we've got to get somebody in like Newsom
or somebody like this young Dynamic
breath of fresh air something different
otherwise they are heading I think to a
complete disaster I loved how you quit
though when you got up The Walker yeah
and you said I'm going to the pub yeah
it's perfect well it was either that or
I was going to Chin are you familiar
with the phrase chili you would be
you've been in England uh chin the guy
that was just gobbing off about me it
was the chin the guy that was gobbing
off well he was he was the deputy
standard
speaking of lofty pedestals here's the
vice president talking about her
favorite topic equity
at all there's an attack right now on
diversity equity and inclusion
where supposed
so-called extreme leaders
are suggesting it's a bad thing to care
about and pay attention to
inequities we must understand what are
disparities
and then
accommodate and adjust for those
disparities if we want
equal outcomes
okay Judge Jeanine your thoughts on
Kamala Harris okay uh now you know why
people don't like her yeah okay I mean
what she just talked about was I mean
equal outcomes we have to I think her
exact words are in addition to what we
said but we have to accommodate and
adjust for disparities and in inequities
so I say to myself well wait a minute
does she mean that in terms of politics
like a race for President should we
um you know adjust for disparities like
think about you know if someone is
running for president and if a minority
in their eyes is running for president
should we make adjustments so that there
is an outcome that recognizes that we
needed to make adjustments for them
hogwash nobody buys that it's ridiculous
but it's what they believe in she's a
full-blown socialist that's what they
want they want socialism and that's why
the Monmouth pulled the fox poll the CNN
poll I mean her negatives are incredible
here's the thing if they're afraid
because of whatever name on The View
says oh we're never going to forgive you
Joe look I don't think Joe's going to
end up running I think this week and
I've said it before on this show the
floodgates opened with um you know with
the opinion piece uh where he shouldn't
run the Washington Post and Ignatius
along with you know Nancy Pelosi not
giving him a ringing endorsement I
really think that now is the beginning
of the end and if they want to if they
want Kamala Harris let her get in the
primary let's see how good she does she
had a drop out of the last primary for
president she did so poorly so you know
what stop with the nonsense we need
someone now we know more than ever how
this you know political identity and and
correctness has destroyed this country
when you don't have someone who's
willing to do the job hero says it's the
beginning of the end hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else